it's a good feeling about what's being
announced today
um I've heard it all before Sammy
Woodhouse was 14 years old when she was
groomed by a gang of men in her hometown
of Rotherham when she asked for help she
says she was ignored ten years ago
people didn't even know what a grooming
gang was so I know that there has been
movement there but I still think it's a
country we are so far behind to where we
need to be to even get into a courtroom
as a victim
um is so incredibly difficult the Prime
Minister was in the north of England
launching new measures to crack down on
grooming gangs but this isn't a new
problem for a decade or more
high-profile cases often involved
British Pakistani men abusing mainly
young white working-class girls and in
many cases including here in Rochdale
where girls were trafficked by men
police failed to act for fear of being
branded racist in 2020 the home office
produced the findings of a major report
which found in fact that in the majority
of cases child sexual exploitation gangs
were actually comprised of white men
and yet the Home Secretary sewella
bravman chose to single out British
Pakistani perpetrators as part of this
Crackdown the Prime Minister not so
explicit all forms of child sexual
exploitation carried up by whoever are
horrific and wrong but with the specific
issue of grooming gangs we've had
several independent inquiries look at
the incidents here in Russia Albert and
Rotherham and Telford and what's clear
is that when victims and other
whistleblowers came forward their claims
were often ignored by Social Workers
Local politicians or even the police and
the reason that they were ignored were
due to cultural sensitivity and
political crackness now that's not right
the government says professionals like
teachers and carers must report
suspicions and cases of abuse or face
prosecution if they don't for a decade
we've been calling for stronger measures
things like mandatory reporting and the
government's turned a blind eye so
anything can now be done to improve the
situation well yes good but I think the
question for the government is what have
you been doing for the last 10 years
victims of child sex abuse say much more
still needs to be done to protect
vulnerable children from the Predators
that want to hurt them Nick Martin Sky
News Rochdale